let's discuss this with radio host
editor-in-chief The Daily wire ben
shapiro who joins us here on set in l.a
pretty good to see so yeah i know you've
been through this racket before with how
they're playing this border issue but
what what is the truth about how illegal
immigration has affected this state this
city this community i mean the cost of
the state are just enormous mean you're
talking billions of dollars it certainly
affected the the city itself it's
affected the level of criminality in the
city it's affected the budget of the
city and it's affected you know pretty
much every aspect of the city including
how the city itself has run so well eric
garcetti was the mayor of the city and
now wants to run for president on the
Democratic ticket right ignores the
55,000 homeless veteran homeless people
not homeless veterans homeless people
11,000 homeless veterans yesterday in
55,000 homeless people who filled Dodger
Stadium just in the city alone and he
wants to run for president but meanwhile
he's gonna virtue signal about illegal
immigration because it's a political
winner in this particularly for the
Democrats to run down to the border I'm
going down there tomorrow they're
running down to the border and like a
whole what what this is just we're
inhumane this is an inhumane series of
actions by Donald Trump you pointed out
during the break how President Obama
viewed the deportation issue in 2014 jeh
Johnson was then homeland security
secretary he explicitly said that we are
taking the measures we are taking to
deport entire families of people as a
deterrent that was his language
deterrent language and now when the
Trump administration used similar
language with regard to separating
families you know I don't think they
should necessarily use that language but
that language is not unprecedented and
the fact is that basically what the left
is saying now is that President Trump
has a choice either he should release
everyone into mainstream society or
they're going to yell and scream because
the law itself says the 9th Circuit
Court of Appeals has made this very
clear that if you arrest the parents you
have to release the kids and that means
you have to separate the kids from the
parents there is no option to keep the
parents in custody with the children
this is just not an option under the law
as written by leftist on the 9th Circuit
Court of Appeals
you know when kids are put into
sponsorships across the country when
they come in unaccompanied sometimes
they were brought in by traffickers they
are sent to sponsors and you realize
that I'm sure our viewers some of them
don't know this some of those sponsors
themselves are illegal immigrants the
HHS regulations do not discount the
possibility of elite
immigrants being sponsors because it's
only one factor so it's more your
financial ability to care for the people
so now illegal immigrants are sponsoring
illegal immigrants in the United States
of America close it out I mean the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals has actually
suggested that perhaps the best policy
would be to take one of the parents and
release them alongside the children so
that we can actually start releasing
more people into societies pretty clear
what the left wants here and for all the
talk about the delays in in you know how
long kids should be in custody the fact
is unless the left released everyone the
unless Trump at least everyone watch
would be deeply unhappy